Stillgelegte Fabriken,
ausgediente Bunker,
verlassene Orte:
Für die einen sind es Schandflecke,
doch für immer mehr Menschen
sind es vor allem
faszinierende Fotomotive.
Sie bezeichnen sich auch als
„Urban Explorer“,
also urbane Entdecker.
Der deutsche Fotograf und
Journalist Arno Specht
erkundet solche verlassenen
Orte seit Jahren.
Seine Kamera hat er immer dabei.
Eine gewisse
Faszination fürs Morbide
oder für außergewöhnliche Orte
war schon immer vorhanden.
So die Initialzündung war
eigentlich ein Zufall.
Vor einigen Jahren hat mein
Sohn mal im Netz
Bilder von den Heilstätten
in Beelitz entdeckt.
Und das war für mich
dann so die Faszination:
auf einmal zu sehen,
dass es ganze Orte,
ganze relativ große Komplexe gibt,
die am Stück sich selbst überlassen sind,
verlassen sind, ihre eigene
Ästhetik entwickeln.
Seit 2007 erforscht Arno Specht vor
allem die ostdeutschen Bundesländer,
dokumentiert leer stehende Gebäude
und deren Geschichte.
Er ist fasziniert von der
Ästhetik des Verfalls.
Mittlerweile hat er vier
Bildbände veröffentlicht:
über Berlin, Leipzig, Dresden
und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Urban-Exploration ist natürlich ’n gewisser
Gegenpol zu einer Welt, die immer
durchgeplanter, inszenierter ... ja
gestylter auch wird, ja?
Wenn ich jetzt hier in so ’n Raum
reinkomme, hier ist nichts geplant,
hier ist nichts aufbereitet, hier ist eigentlich
alles mehr oder weniger ein Zufallsprodukt.
Wenn man sich die Pflanzen anschaut,
die halt eben irgendwo gewachsen sind
im Laufe der Zeit … oder
der Putz, der nach irgendwelchen
Naturgesetzen runterbröselt
– an manchen Stellen hebt er,
an manchen fällt er runter –,
eigene Kunstwerke schafft,
’ne eigene Ästhetik,
wo aber kein Mensch dahintersteckt,
sondern
die einfach nur entstehen, wenn man ein
Gebäude jetzt über 20, 30 Jahre
sich und der Natur und dem
Wetter überlässt.
In den vergangenen Jahren
sind zahlreiche Fotobildbände dieser Art
auf dem Buchmarkt erschienen.
Auch im Netz hat sich das Phänomen
schnell verbreitet:
Zahlreiche Blogs widmen sich dem
Thema Urban Exploration.
Auf Social-Media-Plattformen
wie Instagram oder Facebook
wächst die Community stetig.
Der Boom ist neu, die
Bewegung aber nicht:
Vor gut 25 Jahren hat sich
mit dem Fall der Mauer
gerade in der ehemaligen DDR ein
neues Feld für Urban Explorer eröffnet.
Ein System verschwindet,
und mit dem System verschwinden
auch bestimmte Aufgaben,
bestimmte Institutionen,
bestimmte Einrichtungen.
Natürlich ganze Wirtschaftseinheiten sind
aufgelöst worden, abgewickelt worden.
Es war auf einen Schlag ’n riesen
Umbruch da, der Leerstand verursacht.
Die Bewegung hat ihre
Wurzeln in den USA:
Der industrielle Niedergang
in Städten wie Detroit
führte ab den 1950er-Jahren zum
Verfall ganzer Stadtviertel,
die zum Spielplatz für
Kreative wurden.
Ähnliche Entwicklungen gab
es auch in anderen Ländern.
Eine Immobilien-Krise in
den 1980er-Jahren
tritt in Japan die
Urban-Exploration-Bewegung los,
die dort „Haikyo“ genannt wird.
Auf das mittlerweile große
Interesse in Europa
hat auch die Firma „go2know“ reagiert.
In und um Berlin bietet sie
spezielle Touren an,
bei denen man leer stehende Gebäude
legal besichtigen und fotografieren kann:
Urban Exploration ohne Risiko.
Eine der beliebtesten Touren:
das Haus der Offiziere in Wünsdorf,
rund anderthalb Stunden
von Berlin entfernt.
Auf dem Gelände wohnten im Kalten
Krieg bis zu 60.000 sowjetische Soldaten.
1994 zog die Armee ab,
seitdem steht das Gebäude leer.
Arnas Diemann ist Tourleiter bei „go2know“
Wir haben im Grunde meistens mehr
Nachfrage, als wir anbieten können.
Man kann nicht zu viele Leute auf
die Orte nehmen,
das halten die Orte nicht auf … aus.
Wir gehen ja auch respektvoll
mit den Orten um.
Also, sprich: Wenn wir da zweimal
Touren machen mit 500 Leuten,
dann ist der Ort so hinüber, dass
da nie wieder einer ’ne Tour machen kann.
Und darum versuchen wir im Grunde,
mit kleinen Grüppchen
und aber dafür gehäuft
die Touren anzubieten.
Heute haben sich
18 Teilnehmer angemeldet.
Für 40 Euro können sie das
Objekt in Ruhe erforschen.
Viele von ihnen sind Hobby-Fotografen.
Die Faszination, dass diese Orte
hier mal irgendwann eine Nutzung hatten,
die man auch noch ahnen oder
’n bisschen spüren kann.
Die Ruhe,
Motive, die man sonst nicht sieht,
Orte, wo man nicht hinkommt.
Das ist sehr spannend.
Ich wollt’s sehen und
ich fotografiere es dann ganz nett, dass
man ’n paar Erinnerungsbilder hat.
Ich bin kein Profi-Fotograf,
ich knips hier nur rum.
Urban Exploration hat sich zu
einer weltweiten Bewegung entwickelt.
Arno Specht glaubt, dass dieser
Boom noch eine Weile anhalten wird.